thank you
[Music]
welcome to a very special episode of
careful boys where we are currently off
the Record and today we're talking about
moments of doubt that you had we're all
every day in relationships
but we're what were your first moments
of doubt in your room in the
relationship okay Anthony goes first
yeah he's gonna care for him all right
let's go I'm cool I'll go first let's go
so I've been with my lady since we were
in high school so I thought how many
years now first can we give Nick a round
of applause for going first and actually
wow wow that's the first Super
commendable you know what I totally
agree with you guys that's so crazy I
just didn't notice that people denied it
you know hey don't use me to dunk on
Anthony okay what what no one would ever
do that don't do that that's not cool
you guys are doggy on me again meanwhile
you can purchase this bear brick that is
available on our website or at
kansas.com
what's the difference between this and a
Dunning uh this one's more successful in
swaggy why don't you just use that money
get JK patreon and get crypto Corner
patreon get the [__] out of here both of
those places I abuse and use just
chilling everything right now what else
do you want to say
is way better okay go ahead anyway so
growing uh we've been together for 13
years or whatever uh and uh we were
dating in high school so the first like
you're a whole Junior High and a half
dude the whole like year and a half the
first year and a half I was dating her I
was like I don't even know if this chick
even likes me in a junior or senior yeah
senior year so you were actually with
her officially yeah and you were in you
were just like imposter syndrome as a
boyfriend yeah I was like I was like do
you even like me and [__]
all the time she'd be like yeah what are
you talking about like it's just because
the way she would show love or whatever
it was like very different than the way
like yeah I would oh so what was it was
it she would she didn't say I love you
or what how does she show love and how
do you receive it yeah I think she's
more of a quality time type of lady you
know and I'm more of like
touch me hug me when she was like she
was like stop hugging me so much like I
get claustrophobic please stop oh [__]
she's like she was like that and I was
like what the [__] dude she hates me bro
can I still do that you say you like me
but why would you not hug the person
that you like that's what I would say
all the time when I'm whining about it
yeah chicks love that especially when
I'm trying to be a man
I didn't know you were a physical touch
kind of guy no wonder you do the Jiu
Jitsu I think so I like to touch my
friends too maybe that's why he loses
all the time because he doesn't know
they're supposed to beat them
oh this guy loves me I'm just having fun
I was like you wanna take my back next
how did you get through that with her uh
I just got older and I started to
realize that like oh you're just so
[__] in your own head about [__] but
like that's not there I think it took me
a while though it took me and then you
know beating my lady down with questions
all the time and her just being like no
like what are you talking about like
it's such an insecure age no for sure
dude and I I feel like I feel like that
was just a huge my own issue type of
deal you know but and I knew it was like
I'm the only one that felt this way so
it's [__] weird you were like I feel
like you love me more than no I love you
more than you love me yeah no yeah I
would say dude all the Christians
and you're like oh yeah dude that just
makes my [__] just get that cringe
feel on yourself is that a common Korean
thing because my ex- Korean girlfriend
said that to me she hung out she hung up
on me she was like
I think um we have to break up and I'm
like why she goes because I love you
more than you love me and I'm like how
you know that and she hung up and I was
like what the [__] that's just [__]
dude she just want you to chase her and
then and then she called back she goes
[Music]
yeah oh God and I'm like I just want to
break up because you crazy now
yeah I did the same [__] though on the
other way too yeah like saying that [__]
like I think I like it more than you
like me and [__] oh yeah I think I think
a lot of guys have done that [__] but
you know I think it's very common I
think whether you say it or not it's
probably like part of the maturing
process but you have those thoughts yeah
100 yeah and also didn't share it with
her like that often because I knew like
if I say this I'm putting myself in a
really [__] weird spot so I would
like internalize it and then like and
then sometimes I would be like looking
for evidence in our relationship to
prove that to my head oh no so like that
was like a weird thing for me too but
over time it was just like such a weird
mindset and I think did you guys ever
like break up or take a break no really
no never once since high school yeah wow
we're like I forgot we got some like
argument when we were like younger about
some [__] I forgot it was maybe like two
years in or something and she was like
we should take a break and then my dumb
ass well at the time I probably didn't
handle this right but my mindset was
like what's the point of us going on a
break like we might as well either talk
about it or yeah like come to resolution
or we just [__] end it and call it
quits I don't know if that's the right
thing to do that's my same logic though
I think the same thing I don't
understand what a break is yeah like
what is this called I've had it before
because I just complied yeah it means
you can go [__] around yes is that what
it means it's like I didn't know that I
got a break shoot into single life
exactly well if I [__] knew about
that I would have had
more fun more breaks
seriously I was just like hmm what do I
gotta think about it there's a break
seriously but because brakes you're
supposed to rest so I sat down yeah yeah
it's true people that can't take the
Band-Aid thing you know yeah yeah
exactly they want to break up but they
don't know how to do it yeah and they've
been together for so long they're like
let's take a break because I can see
what happens right it's like a soft
launch exactly yeah biggest
fight or conflict that you you guys ever
had
it was usually some combination of
like me not understanding what the issue
was that she had and it was about like
and it was her trying to make me
understand what the issue was so like
for instance it was like um
I don't want to get into specific why
not why not because it's you know what
was it two on Tuesday or
that the party doesn't want to say no it
was just like um we just looked at an
issue two different ways right so like
she'd be looking at an issue say with
yeah with an uncle or something like oh
his uncle's [__] rude [__] or
whatever he's he's he sucks he's the
worst and I'll be like no you don't
understand my uncle he's just like this
you know like that type of stuff but it
was over a while I started to realize
where she was coming from
with the issue that she had with
somebody or something or the uncle or
whatever I appreciate you trying to stop
your own deflection yeah I know okay
also like [__] opening up like a
firework of ideas and options and I
don't know where you're going to try it
honestly I'm confused because
he's the dude that vowed never to look
at titties again and he's like
[Laughter]
peripherals
I'm confused as [__] but I do like this
[__] you dude
that's good I like when he dumps
[__] you getting
um
thumbnail I kind of see what you're
saying no but you have to replace his
vague now prone like nouns with like
more important people and that's
probably what he's trying to say okay
how about this so it's more family beef
a little like yeah family [__] but then
also too it's like my dumbass doesn't
even understand certain things that's
going on so I have to be more like
present with some of those issues so
then I could be like oh okay and just
have more of understanding be more
empathetic more of one of those like she
didn't feel you got her back in a
familial situation like stuff like that
uh
what the [__] is going on yeah
how about what the [__] is going on yeah
how about what the [__] what's going on
how about yeah dude how about that how
about I didn't want to say yeah but now
uh my back's against the wall and I
gotta say yeah okay so yeah for sure and
then this Uncle world is yeah I mean
yeah or yeah yeah yeah okay
I was trying to find a way to beat
around the bush and I was like I'm not
going to be having your chicks back with
family it's pretty generic General yeah
or just you know why is that something
you want to beat around the bush for I
don't know I don't know why I didn't
want to share it but as I'm saying it
man hey appreciate it no why are you on
YouTube
[Laughter]
because Bart asked me to come
like that hey man some things happened
today just wanted to check my feelings
but uh I don't know which ones but the
you know it's just about kind of like
uncertainty
this house behind him is blurred out
it's completely blurred out yeah
everything that's true it's shown that's
true when his wife like talks like she's
got the [__] CAA Darkness
I'm not gonna show her face ever ever
dude ever thank you for opening up in
the most Vegas
hey bro I'm sweating dude okay we can
actually stop giving Nick credit for
opening up again because now he's closed
back up like a [__] schedule too I'm
like sometimes I really feel when you
guys ask me certain questions I'm like I
honestly just don't have a really good
answer
like if I'm Gonna Keep it a buck I think
I'm very boring in general so it's like
when you guys ask certain things I'm
like oh I don't think I've ever done
that
I've never [__] a fan okay dude I'm
not a fan [__] I like the water you on
YouTube
honestly I don't even know how you why
I'm here he got dragged in by Megan Bart
he just decided to stay this is the most
Nick episode ever see what happens when
you don't go first we get this we get
I'm still somehow I'll fall we get your
[__] fault like hey this is what I
had for [__] lunch try to guess
that's what we get dude hey this is fun
let's guess more things about my life
and I'll try to explain to you guys and
not Beat Around the bush what else do
you guys want to know I'm an open book
baby like it's like we like we like
misprompted the chat GPT and it's just
going I don't know
Jason Chen [__] talk about their
lives all day oh my God the Taiwanese
[__] up Podcast of all time Jason
Cheney and Nick
deflection Channel I understand Jason
Olympics I understand Jason Cheney
because he explains things the way I
would explain things and then I see your
guys react Taiwanese deflectors and I'm
like oh yeah I would be annoyed too if I
was like the difference is he stops
though yeah I keep going
you're trying to talk your way out of
the Mage it just goes they keep getting
stuck it's like me walking into the same
wall over and over again you're
filibustering yourself
too many extra [__] words that don't
go anywhere why he's explaining I was
like yeah I don't think I'm explaining
that am I am I talking
news sometimes okay yeah we keep on
going with this we're gonna get
everybody else have doubts in the
relationship is that the prompt yeah
what about you Bart dude I remember my
first moment of doubt my first moment of
doubt in a relationship when I was
serious was same [__] same [__] High
School right but I'm actually going to
tell you what the [__] happened
[Laughter]
I I was really like you know what you
feel like is in love but you're
infatuated with this chick right and
then she liked the lead singer of
Incubus oh dude Brandon Boyd yeah she's
like that guy Brandon he's dead he's
dead now no no oh yeah yeah no he's dead
[__] beat his ass exactly so so then
that's how Nick could change he was cool
man so then yeah he was cool and like he
was like a hot cute boy and all [__] and
then I just remember being so deeply
insecure about it yeah and like being
like you [__] love him still don't
you and [__] what's your Mario because
she like had like in her notebooks and
[__] she loves them and [__] and I was
like you [__] oh you [__] love him
and then I remember one time uh the
easily the most [__] made moment I ever
can remember
I remember one time I'm sitting there
with her and you're just so [__]
deeply insecure at that age and and
you're like you're like I just I just
like I was looking at her and I was like
you're [__] thinking about how you
love about it
threaded boy
no more we're like in her bedroom dude
yeah and what you say
she said yeah
pretty good read
proud of a mental you'll like to be the
number two no [__] who wants to be
number two but now my wife is basically
married to Eminem
and you shared it you share her you can
break share her uh yeah she's still
yours bro yeah exactly and you're slowly
looking more like him every day
oh [__] come on you gotta play ball
so there you go I [__] shared it all
you want to go again can you put my
deepest darkest moment of like oh that's
[__] boy [__] it is really funny I feel
like what I shared in our early
relationship was pretty [__] boy what
what I said about I don't even know what
you said no details yeah you gave some
Webster's Dictionary definition of like
a conflict
at the later life stuff when I was a kid
and I was like oh you don't love me I
love you like I love you more than you
love me that's pretty [__] I mean it's
pretty good right I was gonna share but
it but it didn't have branded boys um
have like a a girlfriend and then like
go to college or something like that and
you weren't in the same school or Junior
High School some sort of oh that's yeah
yeah grade transfer type it's a thing I
remember having uh I I was a senior and
she was a junior and we were together
and then I graduated this is like one of
my first like longer term girlfriends I
graduated I go to UCI but she's still in
high school
and I had no idea how to navigate this
right let's talk oh that's tight
um it's just one of those things where
like out of sight like it's it's way
more complex you're just like not you're
not great with Communications maybe like
[__] you're not great on the cell
phone whatever it is slash is a [__] ton
of like
intelligent women that are suddenly on
so that's what it's mostly you're about
to say banging honey yeah what are you
talking that's so low so that's what it
mostly
isn't academics but hot Scholars yeah
the hot Scholars
heavy bras there's still a lot of Asians
and that's cool it's not so much but but
yeah it was just a I think navigate did
anybody else have to navigate something
like that maybe we were not like what's
the question
keep going keep going and then so what
happened what was it I maybe only lasted
like a month and a half but I feel like
that first like month because you lost
the will to fight for it but doubt like
just constantly like you're like no but
like I love this you know I love this
person but then you're constantly like
how is this gonna work like I got my
whole life ahead of me were you doubting
you or doubting her or doubting the
relationship relationship yeah because
Tuesday she's still like a great human
being in person and like you know every
now and then I'm still in touch with her
but it's like knowing especially at that
age too like you're like I don't know
how I'm gonna make this work plus like
you know you're so stupid and ignorant
at that time but when you go to college
too suddenly the gap between high school
and college feels so oh massive it's
massive dude yeah oh man like yeah now
you're hanging out with like 21 year
olds all of a sudden like it's PS2 to
PS5 yeah so it's like why would I go
back I went through one of those but I
remember sitting through like a month
and a half of just doubt especially if
the school has graduate school too then
there's 25 to 30 year olds walking
around and you're like I'm in a [__]
adult ass place did she dump it dump it
with you or did you jump with her I
think just the energy slowly started
moving that direction and then like we
kind of had a hard talk but I think she
was really mature about it and like was
understanding and let me off the hook
really easy you broke her heart I didn't
I don't think so Anthony's a
heartbreaker
I don't think I I have always had pretty
amicable like endings of relationships
that's what a heartbreaker would say to
you yeah Heartbreakers say that all the
time do you actually think that she she
maybe was like just being cool or do you
think that she was like maybe
um not like kind of a word too this is
devastated I I think she was being more
cool than she was over it but I also
think that I was trying to be cool
versus like over it you know okay yeah I
think it also like even the crazy thing
is like wow I never spoke about this but
this is fun um the crazy thing was
there's also this girl in my dorm right
after that and me and her clicked like
really well but I had I was so like I
was such a [__] about it I just got a
relationship that I could not make any
moves and then things she knew that I
just got out of relationship and she
just got out of a relationship too so
she also couldn't make any moves and
then it was just known that like we both
were into each other in our freshman
year but never did anything how come you
didn't try to revisit I don't know
sophomore year or something yeah
sometimes when the when the door you
know closes it just it closes damn Jesus
said that he did say that The One That
Got Away
he's labeled he labels it for you
it's like totally not what he's thinking
the title of this is One That Got Away
dude I bet you were you were that guy
for a lot of girls
um what about your uncle nothing about
medical dude hell yeah he is yeah for
sure right all hot guys are
he's a heartbreaker dude I was fat boy
that chick was like oh you should
probably like totally date other chicks
like I'm totally good with it wait
you're a fat during college too no you
weren't fat in college man when did you
lose your weight oh and also right after
college I was fat before college and
after college you lost it for college
you were ready to go dude your prime
time baby damn I was actually scrawny
though so it really wasn't that cool
Paul lanky yeah cool lanky guy did you
like six foot though but that's already
like advantage over most like average
Asian Heights just any person dude how
tall are you it's not 12.
like 12. and when I kissed you earlier
you got nice lips
was it yeah no I I just got mad at you I
was ready I didn't even [__] flip do
it right now dude
but then you still won't be opening up
will you see yeah dude
red-handed [__] you dude what about you
do you have any doubts oh look the
video's over
foreign